thank you maurice yes i'm here with uh
anish giri who had a very uh
tense uh game in round one against the
youngster
uh dak anish take us a little bit
through the game also tell us a little
bit
about your strategy going into this game
you're playing the lowest rated uh
player in the event
did you want to complicate matters and
just go for the kill
well keel is a strong award but uh yeah
i wanted to
to try to play as we had seen very early
on in the round
the way it was on my shoulders i had to
carry this tournament forward there was
nobody else wanted to place us
so um yeah i made sure there is some
excitement after 95 41.
uh well was knight h5 preparing yeah
it's a theory and here the variation
goes knight d7 d5
and then i remember what was going on
there and then if i wanted i would make
sure you have nothing to talk about
today at all because this line
is a fourth draw but uh there is also
this option of takes in 96
that is actually a little risky but it's
quite playable and i thought today is a
perfect opportunity to
to take that risk because uh okay i am
high rated on my opponent and
you know you should take risks and
should probably work out but um
was not so simple uh i didn't really
recall the details i think a3 is an okay
move if i'm not mistaken
but here already i was on my well i
couldn't recall the details but i
i was very happy with the with my
position i thought the huge mistake i
made was here
um oh i see computer gives advantage to
white i didn't think that way very often
when you play
um when you have an ambitious mindset
you start to
overestimate every single balance
imbalance that is in your favor
so as long as there is some imbalance
you always think that well you're on the
good side of things so that was the case
here today
as well and um i realized h4 is a huge
mistake but
i didn't assess i mean i thought um 95
i'm better maybe why didn't you want to
play knight c5 it feels like
i can't say i wanted to include h4 g4
and definitely 95.
and i didn't at all uh allow the thought
that my opponent can
um because this diagonal c5 g1 is very
weak and
somehow i had some some kind of flash
that you know i go a gfg the queen gets
to c5 he goes queen of two i go
and i mean this kind of i mean let's say
something along the lines of
i didn't really see b3 like something
along the lines of suicidal
line like that sort of went through my
head and i thought okay oh great but of
course
upon closer closer examination i
realized that after he bc perhaps i'm
completely lost so
let's uh and then i realized what i've
done it was a disaster i mean
of course 95 first or h495 the
difference is very small
but i was somehow yeah i mean i i was
thinking here about h3 first
which is very interesting and then i
decided that well maybe i will go knight
c5 so i thought that i will take the
decision
move later so the h4 is a good thing to
include but then yeah i realized that i
mean i thought to be honest i
i don't know i see this particular
engine here gives white advantage
i thought during the game that i am
comfortable i didn't feel like
white has an advantage from our
perspective i mean i saw this kind of
stuff
when he goes uh before night uh root 83
i just
didn't i just thought that he has good
drawing chances i didn't okay i see here
why it's better i just thought i'm a
pawn up and
the best that can happen is that we make
some sort of draw but i see that yeah
actually position is probably drawn and
i should probably be precise
um but yeah i i missed b3 and then one
question
one question before we jump to uh too
many conclusions
after q6c5 did you see the move rookie
five
no i didn't i saw okay five i didn't
serve h5
no i saw it five but not with the right
idea but you know i um
i mean i felt to be honest already here
i could i'm this bad yeah i couldn't
believe it i felt i shouldn't be like
here
i shouldn't be so bad my original plan
was queen g5 queen c3 and queen c5
but then i realized that after takes
takes rookie five uh white is on the
good side of the endgame
and at this point i was still assessing
position wrongly i mean
of course compared to what i got in the
game this is better uh also i see now
that white doesn't even have to go for
the end game
i thought yeah this is too hard this
king of one because i give a check can
you two okay
yeah i should have done this anyway so
the thing is i was i had the estimation
of the position wrong i thought black
should be
should be fine and then whenever i saw a
position where i'm slightly worse
i just missed it and i thought that's
this is not the way to go and i realized
um
far too late that i'm in trouble and
here already yeah i mean
queen g7 is such a yeah it's a sad move
i thought to include g4 but yeah g4 was
good and the way he played
i was kind of happy with c5 because i
didn't see
how he wins on the spot i mean this
tactic was above me
obviously and i thought
if there is no direct win you know
positionally it's good to trade this
ugly bishop right positionally it's not
so bad and so i thought maybe i'm okay
and we felt that rookie five might be
the move that he's going to make just
because
it feels like the only move in the
position unless you see this whole thing
that he did in the game
with queen d7 and rook takes c6 because
otherwise i mean i i think that
uh no you consider rookie five you see
g3 and then you can bail out with rook
takes c5
that's the thing you can just take on c5
and bailout
that's why we thought that yeah oh and
then he would hear notice rook has five
right right oh that's uh yeah i see life
uh yeah
it's not always as you think life you
know sometimes you think one thing will
happen uh but then unpredictable things
you know
sure she says no and so on yeah okay so
c5
i thought it was very cool i i thought
at first this is completely strange and
then i saw this quiz six queen d6 idea
and then um yeah then he's still in the
driver's seat
um i think i was am i okay
i'm okay yeah it seems like you're fine
yeah well i'm okay here if k three
b three oh i'm okay okay that's not a
big deal at all
if i'm okay here it's fine how do you
feel about the result
uh the result is it's not about results
to be honest um
you know when whenever they speak about
classical chess and death and so on for
everyone and
the problem in chess is that you've got
results and you've got also
content you know it's a content creator
of course you know what it is content
like um as long as there's content on
the board it's okay
uh but uh so i yeah i mean to be honest
he played okay and i was never in danger
of winning this game so
i think to be honest he's pretty from
what i saw today it's pretty good i mean
i think he's a very solid player he's a
pretty good player it was
hard for me to assess of course he's not
bad anyway but um
i didn't know because i was preparing
and so many games are from some online
tournaments
not even the big ones so from some small
bliss tournaments
and it's very hard to make a good
picture because okay
if you see these blitz games he plays
quite poorly but then i see my blizz
games i also play poorly
there was not enough data to go through
i know he started but i didn't know how
good he is what kind of risk i should
take so yeah i thought i should take
some risk because you never know maybe
later she'll collapse and i'll be the
stupid one you know who didn't take
the opportunity so i tried to play but
from what i saw today
he played well so i don't think i
deserved to win at all and at some point
i was even worried
so i think draw is good and again i mean
i'm happy with um
you know as long as i do my best i i
enjoy life i play chess
i'm happy um so yeah results of course i
want to win but
they can't always that's a very precise
assessment about the dog and his
capabilities and
the result in itself uh what are your
ambitions for the tournament
i know we're only in round one yeah
first place but uh early to speak
because uh
no it's not easy uh very very strong
thai fields also
many of players as you may be okay today
maybe first round but um
well very solid games everywhere so
some players for some reason didn't even
want to to fight so
yeah you'll we'll see maybe things will
get warmed up fabiano is a great fighter
he will definitely
if something he'll start to steer the
drama so i think it's going to get
exciting but
let's see let's see a lot of solid
players well a draw and some content
for the fans yes content thank you anish
and good luck in the rest of our game
thank you
guys back to you thank you christian